bienvenue dans cette nouvelle vidéo
aujourd'hui je vais utiliser google
classroom c'est la rentrée je dois à
réorganiser mais classant créer des
nouvelles et invités de cette vidéo est
destinée aux enseignants qui souhaitent
s'initier à l'utilisation de google
croome
dans leurs classes dans cette vidéo je
vous montrerai notamment comment créer
une nouvelle classe comment inviter aux
élèves comment publier vous votre
premier devoir est aussi comment
archiver tout de suite le générique
génériques
[Musique]
sur google ou vous allez simplement dans
la barre de recherche tapez google
classroom ou alors un outil que
j'apprécie beaucoup c'est le petit menu
applications vous vous retrouvez toutes
vos applications google préféré je tape
sur google chrome et j'arrive
directement sur ma page d'accueil des
événements
vous devrez encoder votre code ainsi que
votre adresse lié à votre établissement
scolaire attention qu ici voilà vous
avez bien le logo est bien l'adresse qui
est liée à l'établissement scolaire
parce qu'il arrive qu avec votre compte
gmail vous essayez de vous connecter
mais évidemment vous n'allez pas sur le
même menu donc vérifiez bien que vous
êtes bien avec votre compte scolaire
alors là on retrouve tous les cours que
j'ai utilisé l'année dernier je vais
d'abord archiver ses différents cours
alors vous c'est un petit peu dans le
désordre parce que vous préférez sans
doute savoir comment créer mais ici je
vous montre déjà comme on peut archiver
un cours c'est assez simple il suffit de
se rendre sur le petit menu donc il ya
trois options et il y à archiver voilà
tout va être archivés dans le drive et
ça ça sera l'objet d'une prochaine vidéo
voilà tout est archivé évidemment je
n'ai plus aucun cours puisque j'aime
tout le mettre aux archives et vous
allez voir que pour créer un nouveau
cours c'est très facile je me rends
simplement sur le petit plus est ici
dans ce cas ci je vais créer un nouveau
le cours que je veux créer ici c'est le
cours de sciences sociales en 6e année
rien de plus rien de moins vous voyez
qu'il est très facile de créer un cours
et un petit temps de latence évidemment
le cours apparaît
et voilà m'ouvre directement le coup je
peux retourner évidemment sur l'écran
d'accueil 6 à 0 élèves d'inscrits
évidemment jan karski personne ni invité
personne mais si je veux j'avais créé
mes différents cours évidemment je veux
voir des tuiles comme c'était le cas
initialement avec les différents cours
que j'ai archives alors bien sûr vous
allez pouvoir vous amuser sur ce court
en changeant éventuellement le thème ce
qui en appelle le thème roues en
intégrant une photo de votre choix
donc ici vous arriver vraiment sur la
page d'accueil du cours que vous avez
créés et vous voyez qu'il y ait en fait
que trois menus possible le menu flux le
menu travaux est de voir le menu
personnes alors on va se rendre dans le
menu personne puisque l'idée ici c'est
quand même d'inviter nos élèves
alors vous voyez qui si vous avez
directement le code du cours qui vous
est proposé invité les élèves ont
communiqué leur le code du court donc si
vous êtes en classe et que les élèves
font un accès à google classroom vous
pouvez leur fournir ce code est en
encodant ce code ils vont directement
rejoindre le cours
comment ça pourrait se passer
éventuellement je peux vous montrer les
lèvres arrivé il ya un petit plus
rejoindre un cours et cliques se
rejoindre un court et il met le code que
vous avez vu précédemment
donc si tous les enseignants craie à
créer un cours l'élève à chaque fois
utiliser le code adéquat et les
différents cours vont apparaître cette
manipulation est à faire qu'une seule
fois ne vous inquiétez pas il faudra pas
refaire ça pour chaque connexion
une fois que c'est fait c'est définitif
et il faut plus se réinscrire alors on
va utiliser une méthode un peu plus
dirigiste et ici je vais directement
invités un élève avait je crée un petit
plus donc je veux mettre le nom d'un
élève fictifs
voilà il est bien dans le domaine donc
il est bien enregistrée pour mon école
et donc son adresse apparaît jeu le
sélectionne je vais faire comme ça pour
les différents élèves
évidemment le code est plus facile si
vous avez 25 élèves
maintenant si vous avez 10 élèves les
adresses peuvent être vite encoder vous
pouvez également ajouter un enseignant
donc imaginons que vous soyez
deux enseignants titulaires du même
cours ou pour une raison x ou y vous
voulez invité un autre enseignant par
exemple un stagiaire
c'est tout à fait possible on peut
également invité des tuteurs mais ça je
ne vais pas rentrer dans le détail doc
évidemment si un parent veut avoir accès
à tout ce qui se passe dans classe qu il
peut avoir accès et avoir un résumé
hebdomadaire qui lui sera envoyée ou
mensuelle et bien voilà vous pouvez déjà
commencer votre court puisque vos élèves
sont invités
alors dans le menu flux vous allez
pouvoir communiquer créer une annonce
éventuellement cette annonce est par
exemple l'échangé d'une ressource
imaginons que je veuille leur communiqué
cette ressource
et bien voilà première ressource et la
pub c'est aussi simple que ça et là tous
les élèves ont accès à cette ressource
éventuellement si je le souhaite je peux
directement communiquer avec un seul
élève n'exigez pas beaucoup d'élèves
évidemment mais je pourrais je pourrais
éventuellement sélectionner les élèves
qui m'intéresse
ça peut être utile en cas de remédiation
ou en cas d'absence d'un élève je veux
qu'ils se remettent à jour et bien je
peux lui envoyer directement des devoirs
si un élève n'a pas compris je peux lui
envoyer aussi des ressources
supplémentaires via ce biais est là à ce
moment là il ya que lui qui les menacent
les élèves éventuellement peuvent
partager aussi des ressources ou poser
des questions directement sur cette
plateforme
on va se rendre dans la plateforme
travaux est de voir puisque c'est là que
vous allez créer des choses auxquelles
les élèves doivent absolument répondre
vous pouvez leur poser une question vous
pouvez aussi créer un devoir
donc là ils vont devoir remettre
un document ça je le verrai dans une
prochaine vidéo je vous montre déjà ici
cette fonctionnalité vient donc vous
avez vu ici comment finalement créé un
coup commment l'archivé comment inviter
des élèves et que moi publié avec ses
fonctionnalités là vous êtes déjà un pro
de google places font car finalement ce
sont les activités principales il n'y a
pas beaucoup d'autres choses que vous
pourriez faire avec ça mais je trouve
que voilà on va à l'essentiel et c'est
ce qui est vraiment efficace dans cet
outil c'est la simplicité des menus et
la prise en main est très rapide en une
dizaine de minutes on a de suite compris
comment ça fonctionne je vous souhaite
une bonne continuation essayé évidemment
l'outil essayer c'est l'adopter je ne
travaille pas pour google mais en tant
qu'enseignant je n'utilise au jour le
jour et j'en suis très content ça me
facilite le travail
je vous en souhaite autant et je suis à
votre disposition sur youtube ou en
direct un pour peser éventuellement vos
questions et j'y répondrai avec plaisir
à très bientôt
coc
ouah
[Musique]
à